bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler du haut qui
vous avez été très très nombreux à me
demander de réaliser un épisode sur la
pensée wok
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui je dois bien
admettre que je ne trouvais pas cette
idée très pertinente
d'abord parce que le hoki ce n'est pas à
proprement parler un mouvement
philosophique c'est plutôt un mouvement
politique ou en tout cas métapolitique
ensuite parce que c'est un courant de
pensée extrêmement récents
et qu'à ce titre on ne peut pas encore
prédire si c'est un courant qui va
marquer l'histoire des idées
le prisme grossissant d'internet fait
qu'on accorde parfois beaucoup
d'importance à des idées qui en réalité
imprègne assez peu la société civile
et la troisième raison et non des
moindres
c'est que la pensée wok
est au centre de nombreuses controverses
c'est ce qu'on appelle un sujet sensible
et
agir
emotionnellement réagir
et donc parler de cette pensée wok
mon s'exposer à la polémique
comme le disait la philosophe simone
weil
quand on fait de la politique
on ne s'adresse plus à la raison mais
aux passions
la politique est une machine à fabriquer
de la passion collective disent elles
or le but de cette chaîne ce n'est pas
de déclencher de la passion collective
sean
de donner matière à penser
matière à réflexion
et
naïf au point de croire
on pourrait traiter un sujet sensible
sans susciter des réactions
alors qu'est-ce qui rend sujet du moc
isme aussi sensible
et bien c'est le fait qu'il touche un
tabou un tabou au sens anthropologique à
savoir le racisme
nous vivons société dans laquelle le
racisme et condamnables et condamnées
si bien par la loi que par la
réprobation sociale
une société où le racisme n'est pas
comme le dit l'expression
une opinion mais un délit
et donc cette question du racisme
cristallise beaucoup d'affect
tu es quelqu'un de raciste ce n'est pas
seulement qualifié ses opinions
celle exclure du champ de la
respectabilité
seulement du fait que durant le xxème
siècle le racisme a été la cause directe
de plusieurs millions de morts
donc il y a un traumatisme
civilisationnel de l'occident sur cette
question
raison pour laquelle on peut parler de
tabou
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que
si tout le monde s'accorde à condamner
toutes les formes de totalitarisme
le totalitarisme raciale est celui qui
suscite le plus de terreur
quel rapport avec le gauchisme
avec le fait que le moc isme soit un
sujet sensible
1 c'est le fait que le voc isme soit un
mouvement
antiraciste
mais qu aux yeux de certains
le hawk isme ne serait qu'un racisme
inversé
autrement dit c'est dit que le voc isme
chercherait pas à combattre le racisme
qu'il pratiquerait le racisme
à l'égard des communautés s'étant rendu
coupable de racisme dans l'histoire
en clair que le hawk isme serait un
racisme anti blanc
et donc là je pense que vous voyez bien
le problème qui apparaît à savoir que
wok et anti works se rejettent
mutuellement la balle du racisme
ce qui donne généralement lieu à des
débats qui n'en sont pas
à des dialogues de sourds où chacun
accuse l'autre de ce dont il est accusé
étant entendu qu'à peu près personne
n'accepte d'être qualifiés de racistes
eu égard à ce que nous avons dit
précédemment
d'aller plus loin et avant de nous
demander ce que le hawk isme 10 de notre
époque
c'est par expliquer un peu les origines
de ce courant de pensée
alors déjà il faut savoir que ce mot ou
autisme
n'est pas une auto désignation
sont pas les wac qui ont inventé le mot
ou autisme
sont les opposants à la pensée voc qui
ont inventé ce mot
dans un but de dénigrement
la même façon qu'au 16e siècle
sont pas les protestants qui se sont
eux-mêmes appelée protestants
ce sont les catholiques qui les ont
désignés ainsi pour pouvoir mieux les
discréditer
donc précisons que lorsqu on emploiera
le mot ou autisme dans cet épisode
ce ne sera pas plus de dénigrement
ce sera par simple commodité de langage
de la même façon qu'on parle aujourd'hui
de protestantisme sans que ça ne soit
disqualifié
donc ou autisme ça vient de l'anglais
wac qui est une déformation du mot awake
et qui signifie éveillé
être rock c'est être éveillé et veiller
à quoi éveiller à la question des
injustices sociales
et plus particulièrement à la question
des discriminations
sont victimes les minorités dans les
démocraties occidentales
le mot le plus utilisé pour englober
toutes ses formes de discrimination
c'est le terme d' oppression
ciot logis ont défini l'oppression comme
je cite le mauvais traitement ou la
discrimination systématique d'un groupe
social avec ou sans le soutien des
structures d'une société
fin de citation
donc l'oppression n'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose d' inscrire
dans la loi
ce n'est pas nécessairement quelque
chose qui est ouvertement assumée par
les structures du pouvoir
c'est en contre or un phénomène diffus
et protéiforme
l'oppression
ifs est épars de la discrimination à
l'embauché
par des injures racistes
par de l'avion ce
feist et par le fait de véhiculer
certains clichés apparemment inoffensifs
l'idée étant que l'oppression du
quotidien et au fond de même nature que
l'oppression organisée
donc il est difficile de dater
l'apparition du mouvement wac
on peut dire qu'il a vraiment pris forme
à partir de 2014
après le meurtre d'un jeune afro
américain nommé michael braun par la
police américaine
sa mort a été vu comme un symbole du
racisme policiers
et par extension
du racisme institutionnel aux états unis
c'est cet événement qui a donné lieu à
la formation du mouvement black la x
matters
avant que ce mouvement ne soit réactivée
en 2020 après la mort cette fois ci de
georges floyd
remonte quelques décennies plus tôt on
s'aperçoit que le mohawk avait déjà été
employé
walk dans le sens de politiquement
éveillé
dans le sens de conscient des
problématiques liées aux discriminations
en 1965 martin luther king a prononcé un
discours dans lequel il appelait la
jeunesse américaine à rester éveillé
sachant que 1965 ça correspond au moment
où les politiques de ségrégation on
commence à être aboli
donc restez éveillés et à entendre ici
au sens de rester vigilant
et près de 30 ans plus tôt en 1938
l'expression stay wac dans une chanson
du musicien noir américain leadbelly
dans cette idée d'être conscient des aux
pressions subies par la communauté noire
donc appelle la pensée wok
art un mouvement de revendication n'est
dans la communauté afro américaine
en réaction à des violences policières
et à des discriminations subies par
cette communauté
et qui avait pour but d'éveiller la
population américaine et en premier lieu
les concernés eux mêmes
à la problématique de l'oppression
mais
le haut qui sera connu une évolution
est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
pensée wok va bien au delà de ce
mouvement initial de défense de la
communauté afro américaine
au delà dans un double sens
la de la communauté afro américaine
puisque ce mouvement s'étend désormais à
l'ensemble des minorités
il n'aurait été sexuelle minorités
religieuses
une aux rites et de genre
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'intersexualité
on va expliquer ça dans un instant
mais au delà aussi dans le contenu du
discours ans
au delà dans la radicalité de la pensée
qui est au fondement de ce mouvement
et vous voir qu'en réalité ces deux
évolutions du oak hills mme vont de pair
alors commence par la première évolution
l'intersexualité
dans les années un timberlake renshaw et
professeur à la faculté de droit de
columbia
et elle développe l'idée que les femmes
noires américaines sont victimes d'une
double discrimination
elles sont discriminés en tant que noir
mais elles sont aussi discriminés en
tant que femme
preuve en est l'absence quasi totale de
femme afro-américaine dans les
mouvements féministes de l'époque
si on ajouté ça la discrimination liée à
la pauvreté
ce qu'on appelle le classicisme la
discrimination liée à la classe sociale
le show en arrive à la conclusion que
les femmes noirs et pauvres sont
triplement discriminés dans une société
dominée par des hommes blancs
c'est ça l'intersexualité
l'idée que les discriminations
s'additionnent
l'idée d'un croisement d oppression
donc par en pl un homme noir sera
opprimés en tant que noir
mais privilégier en tant qu'homme
une femme blanche sera opprimés en tant
que femme mais privilégier en tant que
blanche
et donc il est cible de dresser
une pyramide de l'oppression
sommet de la pyramide les privilégiés
les hommes blancs hétéro ul des classes
supérieures
et tout en bas de la pyramide
de couleur homosexuels et appartenant au
prolétariat
ce qui pose évidemment le problème de la
quantification de chacune de ces
oppressions
savoir si le fait d'être femme constitue
une oppression plus ou moins importante
que le fait d'être noir
savoir si le fait d'être homosexuel
constitue une oppression plus ou moins
importante que le fait d'appartenir au
prolétariat
sans compter les autres motifs de
discrimination
comme par exemple le handicap
ce qu'on appelle le valide isme
le surpoids
la grossophobie
la liste n'est pas exhaustive
et donc selon la donc vous allez
hiérarchiser les oppressions vous
n'allez pas arriver au même résultat
mais dans tous les cas et c'est là qu'on
on arrive à la deuxième évolution du
gauchisme
des centrales de la pensée wok c'est
qu'il existe des groupes opprimés
coupe oppresseurs
groupes discriminés et des groupes
favorisés
existent dans la société un système de
privilèges
dont les uns bénéficient et dont les
autres sont exclus
or quelle est la catégorie qui
s'accaparent l'intégralité des
privilèges
c'est la catégorie de l'homme blanc
hétérosexuel des classes supérieures
et c'est là évidemment que la
controverse pointe le bout de son nez
on disait tout heures que le hawk isme
était un sujet sensible
quoi
parce que le hoki sme est un mouvement
anti raciste et anti discrimination
c'est un mouvement qui entend dénoncer
et combattre les injustices dont font
l'objet les minorités
bon bah ça a priori ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est de nature à créer la
controverse
même les gens les plus intolérants même
les gens les plus réactionnaires dans
leur vision de la société
sont capables de reconnaître qu'il est
juste de combattre les injustices
par définition
mais la contre arrive quand il s'agit de
désigner les auteurs de ces injustices
c'est à dire la catégorie des
oppresseurs
partant du sip que s'il y a des opprimés
c'est qu'il y a des oppresseurs il
convient de nommer les oppresseurs pour
mieux les combattre
pas que nous sommes dans un mouvement de
revendication
avec ce que cela implique en termes de
conflits que tu alité
or l'oppresseur ne peut être que celui
qui bénéficie des normes sur lesquels
est construite la société
dans les sociétés occidentales
si on est historiquement une population
blanche
le pouvoir a été historiquement détenus
par des hommes
la norme a été historiquement
l'hétérosexualité
et les plus privilégiés ont été
historiquement les riches
et cette catégorisation sociologique de
la domination
cette idée de strates de privilèges au
sein de la société
ça nous conduit à un autre concept
fondamental de la pensée wok à savoir
l'oppression systémique
son système etc autrement dit la
domination structurelles
nation ancrée dans les rouages de la
société
marx disait que l'économie représentait
l'infrastructure de la société
autrement dit que la domination
s'exercer d'abord sur des bases
économiques
les propriétaires capitalistes sont les
dominants et les prolétaires sont les
dominer
dans la vie ok c'est pas seulement la
position économique qui détermine le
statut de dominants ou de dominer
c'est la position
sociologique
et la position sociologique comprend à
la fois la race le sexe le statut social
l'orientation sexuelle ou encore les
capacités physiques
donc appartenir à une catégorie
minoritaires de la société
c'est de fait être sous le joug d'une
oppression systémique
pourquoi parce que les normes en vigueur
dans une société
sont les normes de la majorité
par définition
est donc s'écarter de la norme dévié de
la norme c'est et en situation de
minorité est donc en situation
d'oppression
un exemple le cas des personnes
homosexuelles
historiquement les sociétés occidentales
la plupart des sociétés dans le monde
et par la norme de l'hétérosexualité
l'homosexualité a longtemps été
réprimées
en france elle fut l'airé comme un crime
jusqu'en 1792
et ce n'est qu'en 1982 que l'âge de la
majorité sexuelle pour les personnes de
même sexe fut abaissé à 18 ans comme
pour les personnes de sexe opposé
donc il ya dans les sociétés
occidentales ce qu'on appelle un
principe des terreaux normativité qui
fait que de manière structurelle de
manière systémique donc
personnes homosexuelles subira des
discriminations
et ce indépendamment des intentions des
auteurs de ces discriminations
on va le dire autrement
hawke dans une société hétéronormée
l'homophobie est structurel
puisque par d selon la norme exclu ce
qui n'est pas elle
donc les membres d'une société
hétéronormée peuvent ne pas avoir le
sentiment d'être homophobe
ils peuvent ne pas avoir l'intention
d'exclure et de discriminer les
personnes homosexuelles
ils le font inconsciemment
existerait un inconscient socioculturel
qui ferait de toute personne appartenant
à une minorité la victime systémique de
toute personne appartenant à la majorité
hausse pour le racisme
dans une conception rock le racisme
n'est pas seulement l'expression
consciente et volontaire d'une exclusion
de celui qui appartient à une autre
ethnie
le racisme est un phénomène structurel
crimine structurellement celui qui
n'appartient pas à l'ethnie majoritaire
donc le racisme n'a pas besoin d'être
conscient de lui-même pour exister
il est une conséquence mécanique des
structures normative de la société en
l'occurrence des sociétés où les blancs
sont majoritaires
alors évidemment pour bon nombre d'entre
nous
du 21e siècle
cette vision de la société
cette vision des catégories
sociologiques au sein de la société
et bien elle tranche un peu avec notre
conception historique de la société
pour le dire simplement
c'est une pensée qui nous choque
le choc
oc à deux niveaux
elle nous choque un premier niveau parce
que nous savons que l'oppression n'est
pas systématiquement exercée par la
majorité
marx est un penseur qui a bien montré en
quoi l'oppression étaient exercés par
une minorité
la minorité bourgeoise la minorité
détentrice du capital
et de ce point de vue là la majorité
c'est bien plutôt la main d'oeuvre de la
minorité capitaliste
et puis un deuxième niveau ça nous
choque parce que nous avons
majoritairement une conception
républicaine et universaliste de la
société
or la vision walk ne repose pas sur un
modèle universaliste
modèle communautariste
alors explique ont un peu sans
en 1704 a eu lieu la révolution
française qui a aboli les privilèges en
tout cas officiellement
et qui a accouché du concept de
citoyenneté
le citoyen c'est celui qui un d son
origine ethnique
indépendamment de sa religion ou de ses
croyances
et membre de la nation
ced exactement les mêmes droits que tout
autre membre de la nation
c'est ce qu'on a longtemps appelé le
creuset républicain
le fait que la république soit comme un
récipient à creuser donc
pouvait accueillir toute personne d'où
qu'elles viennent et quel que soit ses
croyances dès lors qu'elle épouse et le
projet républicain c'est à dire
le projet de la fraternité entre
concitoyens
une république et citoyens son frère
toujours sur sur
et cette fraternité transcende les
appartenances identitaires et
communautaire
la république ne reconnaît pas de
communauté
elle ne reconnaît que des individus
ans
ac a été instauré la loi sur la laïcité
dite loi de séparation des églises et de
l'état
qu'est ce que nous dit cette loi
le mans que le catholicisme ne sera plus
la religion officielle de l'état
donc cette loi s'inscrit totalement dans
le prolongement du projet universaliste
républicain
puisqu'elle consiste à inscrire dans la
loi le fait que l'état n'a pas à prendre
partie dans les affaires religieuses
que l'état est désormais neutre sur le
plan des croyances religieuses
ce qui confirme l'idée que le principe
de l'universalisme républicain
c'est le pluralisme
c'est la tolérance vis-à-vis de toutes
les identités
aidants on dit que s'il n'y a plus de
religion d'état
tout le monde peut pratiquer la religion
de son choix
ce qui d'ailleurs au passage explique
une grande partie des querelles
auxquelles on assiste quand on parle de
laïcité en france
puisque les uns y verront un rejet par
l'état de toutes les religions
tandis que les autres y verront au
contraire une acceptation par l'état de
toutes les religions
donc la con
société qui est historiquement celle de
la france c'est un héritage direct de
cet universalisme républicain
et qui nous rend particulièrement
chatouilleux
pour ne pas dire sourcilleux
dès qu'on aborde la question des
communautés de l'ethnie et plus
généralement de l'identité
en france parler d'identité et notamment
d'identité ethnique c'est mal vu
parce que la république est basé sur le
principe de la simulation
l'idée que ce n'est pas l'origine
ethnique ou la couleur de peau
qui détermine notre identité nationale
publique française ne repose pas sur une
conception ethnique de l'identité
elle repose sur une conception
culturelle de l'identité
on est français parce qu'on a choisi
d'être français
parce qu'on en épouser la culture
parce qu'on en épouser les valeurs et le
projet
voir à ce propos ouvrage dernier ce
trône ans
ce qu'une nation dans lequel renom
explique bien la différence entre
ethnies et nation
et où il montre que l'identité française
ne repose pas sur une ethnie
mais sur un projet commun
à la différence par exemple des
allemands
pour lesquels la nation est
fondamentalement lié à l'ethnie
de même pour la religion
en france on le disait un instant
de religion officielle
alors hertz aux états unis
on prête serment sur la bible
les billets de banque il est écrit in
god we trust
ce qui en france me paraît très
complètement incongru
parce que nous n'avons pas la même
histoire que les états unis et donc nous
n'avons pas la même conception ni la
même définition de l'identité nationale
et donc si la pensée walk un sens dans
un contexte américain
elle est beaucoup plus problématique
d'un point de vue français
la désignation de communautés
la séparation des communautés les unes
des autres
ça n'a rien de choquant aux états unis
c'est même quelque chose de très banal
alors que d'un point de vue français
désigné des communautés
se regrouper par communauté
par communautés ethniques par
communautés culturelles ou religieuses
on appelle ça du séparatisme
vive entre blancs ou entre noirs ou
entre asiatiques
en france
on appelle ça du racisme
parce que ça soude andré une volonté de
la part de ces communautés de ne pas se
mélanger
de rester entre soi
et ça pour nous français c'est la
définition même du racisme et de la
xénophobie
en france
il est le mot race c'est déjà une marque
de racisme
et que l'humanité serait divisé en
plusieurs races
c'est du racisme
alors qu'aux états unis
parler de race ça ne pose pas de
problème
ça ne choque personne
identité américaine
la race
et une personne métis on ne la qualifie
pas de métisses
on la qualifie de bi raciale
le mot métis est vu comme une insulte
aux états unis
parce que métis c'est un terme qu'on
réserve aux plantes
les plantes métis
donc vous voyez qu entre la france et
les états unis on est sûr de logiciels
très différents
et comprendre ça c'est comprendre les
raisons qui font que la pensée walk a
quelque chose de choquant pour nous
français
parce que de même que les cultures ne
sont pas identiques ni interchangeables
les pensées et les idéologies issus de
ces cultures ne sont pas non plus
identiques ou interchangeables
on n'efface pas trois siècles d'histoire
politique d'un coup de crayon
passez pas d'un antiracisme
universaliste et laïque un antiracisme
communautariste et identitaire sans
créer quelques perturbations neuronale
et ignorez sans ignorer le fait qu'il y
a une différence d'épistémologie
politique entre le logiciel
universaliste et le logiciel
communautariste
s'interdire de comprendre pourquoi la
pensée wac rencontre des oppositions
et compris au sein même des mouvements
progressistes
la gauche républicaine défend depuis
environ trois siècles l'idée qu'on juge
pas un citoyen à sa couleur de peau ou à
sa religion
et la gauche identitaire walk lui
explique maintenant que la couleur de
peau et la religion sont absolument
décisif dans l'organisation des rapports
sociaux
disons le encore plus clairement
selon les critères de la gauche
républicaine et laïque la pensée wok
une pensée raciste
puisqu'elle fait de la race et de
l'identité ethnique
un élément social déterminant
donc on est en plein conflit des
postulats
on est en plein conflit des paradigmes
politique
reprenons l'exemple de la religion en
france le principe de laïcité signifie
que critiquer une religion n'est
absolument pas équivalent au fait de
critiquer le peuple qui pratiquent cette
religion
ce que la religion relève de la croyance
donc de l'esprit
pas de l'ethnie
pas de la biologie
critiquer stanis mme s'était pas
critiquer les italiens
ou les portugais ou les polonais
la laïcité c'est la séparation son de
l'église et de l'état mais c'est aussi
la séparation de la croyance et de la
personne
on critique une croyance pas une
bon et bien états unis ou en angleterre
on voit les choses différemment
aux états unis et en angleterre
l'islam ce n'est pas critiquer une
croyance
aux états unis et en angleterre
critiquer l'islam c'est du racisme
parce que ces critiques et la croyance
d'une population dont l'identité se
confond avec la religion
vous avez peut-être vu passer cette
interview de caroline fourest sur sky
news en 2015
dans laquelle elle présente à l'écran
des caricatures du prophète de l'islam
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien
c'est que l'interview a été interrompue
et la journée présenter des excuses aux
téléspectateurs
a jugé comme on jauge au royaume-uni que
critiquer l'islam à l'antenne ce n'est
pas critiquer une croyance
c'est offenser une communauté
c'est ça la conception communautariste
de l'identité
et dans cette sion c'est la laïcité qui
est vu comme une forme de racisme
parce que la laïcité impose le silence
aux religions
parce que la laïcité permet d'insulter
les religions
alors que la religion fait partie de
l'identité des peuples
voyez
ferron
et on ne peut pas
différence n'existait pas
quand des pères tu es de gauche dénonce
ce qu'elle identifie comme étant des
dérives de la pensée wac
elles ne le font pas parce qu'elles sont
passées du côté de l'ennemi
elles ne le font pas en raison d'une
soudaine conversion au racisme
elles le font au contraire sur la base
d'une conception républicaine et
universaliste de l'antiracisme qui
estiment à tort ou à raison que m
l'identité au centre du débat qu ramener
les personnes à leur couleur de peau à
leur race ou à leur religion c'est
l'essence même du racisme
à des anti raciste devenu raciste
on a affaire à deux conceptions
diamétralement opposées de l'antiracisme
une conception universaliste qui nie les
différences entre les peuples et les
communautés
et une conception communautariste
qui voit dans ces différences entre les
peuples et les communautés
l'origine de toutes les oppressions
pensez vous qu
parler de privilèges blanc
parler de masculinité toxiques
parler de culture du viol
ce n'est pas choquant
c'est juste nommer les choses
c'est juste désigné les coupables
c'est juste ouvrir les je
donc il ya quelque chose chose de
nouveau dans la pensée hook
désigné comme coupable de l'oppression
pas une caste d'individus mais une
communauté d'individus
pour les looks être blanc c'est
bénéficier du privilège blanc
être hétérosexuel
c'est bénéficier
hétéro normativité
et être un homme c'est bénéficier du
patriarcat
la question
voir quelle idée on défend
la question est de savoir
à quelle communauté on appartient
carlo pression n'est pas une affaire
d'idées
mais une affaire d'identité
les noirs n'ont pas oui mais pour leurs
idées
noir
les homosexuels
et aux primés pour leurs idées
mais parce qu'ils étaient homosexuels
les femmes a été opprimé pour leurs
idées
et parce qu'elle est et femmes
partant de ce la pensée walk estime que
ce ne sont pas les idées qui conditionne
les rapports de domination
retenons ce communautaire
romandie
celui qui ne pense pas comme moi
l'ennemi est celui
appartient à la communauté dominante
il ya donc dans la pensée walk
une essentialisation de l'oppresseur
une essentialisation
c'est à dire qu'on ne cherche pas à
convaincre l'oppresseur de cesser d'être
un oppresseur
puisqu'il l'est quoi qu'il fasse
ce n'est pas une
d'idées ou de valeur
c'est une question d'appartenance
communautaire
en duo qu on ne sentent pas son
appartenance communautaire
un blanc qui a des dreadlocks
ce n'est pas un blanc qui épouse la
cause des noirs
est un blanc qui fait de l'appropriation
culturelle
n
ministre ce n'est pas un homme qui
épouse la cause des femmes
c'est un homme qui
à se donner bonne conscience
c'est la raison quel l'ewok sont très
attachés à la parole des concernés
pour parler de racisme pour parler de
féminisme ou d'homophobie il faut être
concernés
concerné ça veut dire faire partie de la
communauté visée par ceux dont on parle
la partie d'une de ces communautés
opprimés
notre parole notre témoignage
une abstraction
par les deux concernés et de non
concernée s'est déporté le noyau du
militantisme politique
de la pensée à l'identité
fini politiquement par son appartenance
communautaire avant de se définir par
ses idées personnelles
alors ça peut nous paraître choquant
mais quand on y réfléchit ça peut se
justifier
quand marx décrit la domination
capitaliste
il ne propose pas aux capitalistes de
donner leur point de vue
ceux qui sont concernés par la
domination capitaliste
ce sont les prolétaires
c'est à dire les dominer
eh bien c'est la même chose pour les
boucs à cette différence près que dans
la pensée walk ce n'est pas seulement la
position économique qui définit le fait
d'être concerné ou non
c'est la position communautaire
un blanc n'a pas à parler du racisme que
subissent les noirs parce que lui même
ne le subit pas
à paroles ne pourrait être qu'une parole
abstraite
relapse traite et sans aucune valeur
c'est ça le fait d'être concerné
on se souvent
x militant afro américains
qu'une jeune journaliste blanche était
venu lui dire qu'elle était très attaché
à cette cause et qu'elle lui avait même
demandé si elle pouvait faire quelque
chose pour l'aider
le comics l'avait laissé parler
et une fois qu'elle a eu fini
il lui avait tout simplement répondu
avec un petit sourire
non
non parce que le combat identitaire
n'est pas un combat d'idées
et donc évident on la question qui se
pose c'est de savoir
pourquoi y at il parmi les militants
book
parfois même parmi les plus zélés des
militants rock
des noms concernés
des blancs pour joie hétérosexuels
pourquoi y at il parmi les militants
rock des privilégiés
est ce que ces militants se rendent
compte
s'approprie un combat qui n'est pas le
leur
un combat dans lequel en tant que non
concernés leur parole n'a pas de valeur
à moins que des noms concerné n'est de
valeur que lorsqu'elle va dans le sens
des intérêts dus au kiss me
il y a eu le cas d'une activiste
américaine jessica crous
sera l'université george washington
qui pendant des années a fait croire à
ses étudiants qu'elle était d'origine
africaine
et dont on a fini par découvrir qu'elle
s'était inventé ses origines pour se
donner une légitimité sur le sujet
110 longs
alors bien sûr c'est un cas isolé
mais sans dit long sur le besoin qu'ont
certains progressistes blanc
se réclamer d'une identité exotique pour
se sentir appartenir au camp des
opprimés
on se dit un ancêtre espagnol et en ce
sens appartenir à la communauté des
immigrés
comme si l'identité n'avait de valeur
qu'en dehors de nos propres frontières
et c'est pour ça qu'on peut comprendre
le succès de la pensée wok
chez de nombreux militants progressistes
blanc hétérosexuel
c'est à dire chez des militants non
concernés
si on comprend pas le ressort
psychologique fondamentale qui les anime
à savoir la culpabilité
l'occident on est habité par la
culpabilité
pendant d kl l'occident à imposer son
modèle aux autres civilisations
il l'a imposé par la force il l'a
imposée par la religion
économie
par la technologie
et il continue de l'imposer par la
propagande médiatique
le fameux soft power
sanon voix 1 depuis quelques décennies
l'occident clean
de nouvelles puissances économiques ont
émergé
chine l'inde le brésil la russie
et l'occident à perdre paul
et en perdant son monopole il a aussi
perdu sa légitimité
l'occident n'est plus en position de
son au monde
et du coup l'occident retourne sur lui
même
il constate ce qu'il a fait
et il veut
il s'en veut parce qu'on ne s'en veut
que lorsqu'on a plus les moyens
imposer sa légitimité
veut que lorsqu'on est confronté
aux conséquences de nos actes
l'occident ses comptes la conquête
est aujourd'hui l'occident nous dit
la conquête c'est mal
l'occident
violence est aujourd'hui l'occident nous
dit
la violence c'est mal
l'intolérance ce c'est mal
le racisme c'est mal
l'occident
dans l'ère de la déconstruction
jacques derrida disait la dépense l'on
sait ce qui arrive
c'est ce qui arrive
elle disait que l'histoire
tu es retour sur soi
on se sur nous-mêmes
et on pleure
on pleure pour ce qu'on a fait
pour ce qu'on a fait subir
pour les fautes qu'on sait ne jamais
pouvoir être réparé
et parce qu'on sait jamais pouvoir les
réparer
punis
on se si
la dépense on est le produit de la
conscience de soi
devient mauvaise conscience
lorsque cette conscience devient
culpabilité
elle devient
ce honteuse
la honte de soi
la honte da retenir
désavoué par le monde
un occident mis en face de ces méfaits
et qu'il peut son salut que dans la
repentance
demander pardon
demandé par pour l' esclavage
demandé pardon pour la colonisation
demandé pardon
devant l'histoire
les nomades sme
c'est à dire la honte d'appartenir à un
peuple en l'occurrence à l'occident
c'est l'expression d'un désir
de devenir les opprimés à la place des
opprimés
ir de s'infliger ce qu'on a infligé
pour se racheter une bonne conscience
pour sauver
on s'incline devant celui qu'on a
opprimé
pour oublier le fait qu'on l'a opprimés
on averses les rôles pour espérer
rembourser sa dette
dans l'île des esclaves de marivaux
les esclaves deviennent les maîtres et
les maîtres deviennent les esclaves
parce que ce n'est qu'en vivant la cie
sion de l'opprimé
que l'on cesse d'être un oppresseur
quand amy oak blanc se retrouve filmé en
train d'embrasser les chaussures
d'hommes et de femmes issus des
minorités
je n'invente rien
il exprime la mauvaise conscience de
l'occident
l'hôte humiliation comme moyen de
réparer ses fautes
tuez moi pour ce que mes ancêtres ont
fait
tuez-moi pour les crimes de mon peuple
tu es moi
parce que je mal
mais le plus ironique dans cette
histoire c'est de finalement constater
que la récupération du mouvement rock
par des non concernés
le fait que des occidentaux blanc
veulent se placer à l'avant poste de ce
mouvement
velk effectivement
l'occidentale
se mêler de tout
que l'occidental ce qu'on soit
effectivement comme le représentant du
bien et du juste
que l'occidental est spécialisé dans
l'art
de faire la leçon au monde
car même lorsqu'il est mis en accusation
trouve le moyen de s'exprimer au nom des
concernés
en épousant la cause des opprimés
en intégrant le parti des opprimés
look
s'approprient leur statut
il s'engage dans une cause qui n'est pas
la sienne
au nom de la solidarité l'été et de la
fraternité
sans voir que c'est d'abord un moyen
pour lui
de ne plus se sentir coupable
l'opprimé et l'instrument de sa bonne
conscience
alors s'il occidental veut des comptes
son histoire
s'il occidental veut
se regarder dans le miroir et dire voilà
ce que je suis
qu'ils sachent
tu
ne s'obtient pas en apprenant aux
opprimés
je vous remercie
[Musique]